okay this question comes from the chat
so it's not on your list this is laura
sosa who says forgive a novice here what
are your thoughts on retro causality
quantum entanglement
time perception and precognition studies
well it's an interesting question
about
the only argument i've ever seen
from the sciences
on
why there can't be free will
is
retro causality
uh the argument that
if
in our
life experience x
precedes systematically y and we take x
to cause y
and if it seems that
we're carrying out an act say am i
lifting my finger
just because i decided to do it
at some
level maybe the
you know not the level of experience
there's an argument that
time is reversible
which means that
the
lifting my finger could have preceded
the decision to do it
which seems to conflict with the
idea that i decided to do it
i personally don't think that's
a very persuasive argument but it's uh
it is
at least one argument i think probably
the only argument
that comes from the sciences
against the
universal belief which we all have
whether we
deny it or not
that we can make decisions about our
next action
you